[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's andrew brent the
mondaymorningquarterback.com former
nfl executive and it was a couple of
weeks ago when andrew brant
joined us here on the program and had
this to say
okay can you guarantee that carson wentz
and dusan watson will
not be traded you got to put something
up here andrew
yeah you guarantee something
yeah i'm going to guarantee you okay
what are you willing to put up
i say again what are you willing to put
up
i'll come back on your program and gain
the wrath of all the haters
saying brandt you were wrong i mean i
don't how about
how about a a liquid cheese bath
because you used to be with the packers
so yeah
would you do a liquid a a shower of
cheese on the show wisconsin cheese
yeah you'll do it i wear that helmet
behind me you can wear the helmet
but you would do a a shower of cheese
would you do that
i will if if they're not on their teams
i will do that
i will do that dan okay all right
andrew brant joining us did you know
that i was going to play that that's why
i was having you back on today
you know i'm a lawyer too among my
titles and i'm going to
uh use my legal training here
there was an and in there right so we're
only one for two right now
so the and includes desean watson so
i'm not ready for that shower yet but
i'll continue to double down
and say it listen the once thing
i am shocked still not only that they
took on the 34 million in dead money
that they did it for a return of
investment that just
seems marginal for someone they put in
multiple number one picks and 80 million
dollars and
gave him the keys to the franchise and
let foals go
i mean it's just amazing that happened i
underestimated dan
the breach of trust between the eagles
front office
and carson wentz that could not be
repaired so i guess
i'm halfway towards that cheese shower
but you know my legal training there was
an
and in there not an ore i know
using semantics and i did hear that um
you know that uh the the lawyer in the
room mclovin well he wasn't a lawyer
paralegal paralegal okay yeah yeah i
mean that's almost a lawyer right
it's pera
all right so looking back on that deal
did the did the colts
win that deal yes
in a word yes i mean listen the way we
look at future draft picks in the nfl at
least from my time with the packers was
you look a year out that's a round lower
so
basically they got carson wins for
two-thirds
for two-thirds that's the present value
of the deal is two-thirds now that
second one can go up based on
performance but uh
you talk about carson wentz for
two-thirds now again it depends what you
think of the player if you think he's
broken
sure i mean maybe the eagles got a
decent deal but
look at what the eagles are taking on a
historic amount of dead money
you know for a third round pick and
hopefully a second or the first next
year i mean it
yeah the colts won that deal and now you
have a situation
a situation with russell wilson and one
with deshaun watson
so let me start with desean watson
because you don't think he's going to be
traded
do you still think he won't be traded
given
the acrimony that's going on with the
front office and that he told
his new head coach that he didn't want
to be there yeah i mean listen what did
i what did i just say about wence i
underestimated the emotional
trauma between the two sides and i'm
still going to hold firm on watson
but we may be having a different
discussion now here's a hedge
we may be having a different discussion
in september because i look at it from a
leveraged point of view what is desean
watson's leverage
he has none you know what are you going
to do miss zoom meetings for the next
four months
that's really no leverage now you could
say well the texans got to do it before
the draft to get draft capital and i
keep coming back to
who cares about draft capital if you
have desean watson you know right
i'm not taking four number ones for that
doesn't help me
you know when we talk about deshaun or
russell wilson
you're not getting the same player from
all the packages that are being offered
wait
you wouldn't take four first-round picks
for deshawn watson
i mean if you can guarantee that that
team's gonna be in the top ten every
year no
no like carolina carolina is in a
rebuild
if carolina said we'll give you three
number ones and christian mccaffrey
no what would it take to get russell
wilson in your opinion
well let me tell you what it would take
to get desean watson or russell wilson
okay give me your quarterback give me
your number ones
couple and let me look at that roster
and pick off your top offensive young
rookie contract player and your top
defensive young
rookie contract player proven proven i
don't want picks
yeah you know and again so what so what
i'm saying is
stupid deals right stupid
stupid deals not carson wentz and the
colts not jared goff
stupid deals and listen deshaun watson
is telling david coley i'm not going to
play for you
but again i keep going back to okay
what his leverage is just to do what
jalen ramsey did a couple years ago in
jacksonville
get there and be a pain in the butt
you know that's really the leverage to
get to be
not a hold out because hold out you're
going to get all that financial
penalties from
cba you're going to screw yourself
financially hold in
you know that's the new leverage for
players hold in but that doesn't happen
until
august what do you make of russell
wilson's agent
saying that there's four teams hey i
wanna we wanna stay
but just in case there are four teams
that he would wave is no trade to so
what what is
what is the game plan here with russell
wilson you know when i heard him on your
show on this show
i was shocked dan because you know as
well as i do russell is
bland corporate unrevealing go hawks you
know
that was a massive change when i heard
him on this program
massive so something's up and basically
what i'm gathering is some of it's brady
envy you know look what he got but he
took 20 years for tom to get that
and some of it is just frustration that
he doesn't have more of a role
this one's different dan because i'm not
sitting here
steadfast like i was with once and i'm
with watson because
we haven't heard from the seahawks you
know we haven't heard from the seahawks
and there's a lot of leakage going on
they weren't happy with some of the
things he did he's not happy with some
things they're not coming out and saying
no way know how no way in god's green
earth we're trading russell wilson
so what i think his agent put out there
was hey
we see your leaks you know and we raise
your leaks
we raise your legs if you're we're not
asking for a trade that was the message
okay don't blame us but if he's traded
this is where he wants to go so my my
rep message from that was hey
don't take calls from the jets you know
don't take calls
from the panthers because it's not
happening but if you get calls
from the bears and raiders and saints
okay you know
so i don't you know i'm not a steadfast
i don't think he'll be traded because i
don't think the package will match the
value
but clearly there's a rift between it
whether it's pete carroll or john
schneider or both
and and and russell's camp about where
this is going
but i've always thought that they they
don't know their offensive identity
it feels like their identity changes now
bill belichick famously can change his
identity
from one quarter to the next or one week
to the next
but it's bill belichick who's doing this
i always tune into a seahawks game and
it's like a crooked score
going into the fourth quarter it's like
you know 13
to nine and they're losing and then it
feels like pete carroll goes uh
and running game didn't work hey russ go
out there and win the game for us
they let him cook in the first half of
the season but then
the second half of the season all fell
apart
i i just don't know as they move forward
is this just about offensive line
protection
because i'm not sure what russ wants
in this say-so in the organization so
how do you placate him
because pete carroll's 70 andrew he's
not there for a rebuild
yeah i know listen i i'm the same with
you when i watch the seahawks it looks
like okay russ
bail us out and now they had they had
daryl belleville back in the day you
know the super bowl they had
brian schottenheimer this year and i
thought
maybe there was some friction there but
brian shot number's gone
so they have a new offensive coordinator
that supposedly russ
you know seems to get along with so
we'll see what happens but
yeah i don't see it either but listen i
work seven years with john schneider
john is a an aggressive
gm you know from percy harvin to jamal
adams
he's an aggressive gm but usually he's
the aggressor on the intake
right the piercy harvin's the jamal
adams
he's not in the aggressor on the outtake
so to take a bunch of picks or whatever
it is for russell wilson
so that's why just this doesn't sit well
but i think
the seahawks are frustrated with russell
and vice versa whether that results in a
trade i think that's a big leap
but if you're the seahawks do you call
the cowboys do you call the saints do
you call the bears do you call the
raiders
yeah i guess you do just to see if like
i talk about it there's something stupid
out there
i don't know what they think of dak
prescott i mean people you know sort of
put these things
together you know whether he would fit
with them and whether i don't think the
cowboys want to move on from prescott i
think that's going to be another
tag frankly you don't think jerry jones
you know how jerry is he loves shiny new
objects
and is this leverage with dak prescott
to go you know what let's
let's look at russell wilson i don't
know
just a quick minute on deck i think he's
in great shape despite the injury he's
got three choices
franchise tag 38 million do a deal that
he likes
or be set free in the in the market
which the cowboys won't happen which
would make even more than anyone
so dak's in great spot right now
financially uh
we have an i-team investigation
hold on andrew investigation the motto
of
our news team is fast and wrong is still
fast let's go to the newsroom paulie
dan andrew brant lawyer eric quotes uh
said that
by the use of the word and with carson
wentz and desean watson
he is on hold with the cheese flume bet
okay we have further audio to illuminate
details of this situation here we have
it okay
i'll do the cheese if uh either one of
these guys is not traded
okay if one of them's traded then
you're gonna be a true cheesehead
and you are as well yes i will yes i
will
oh my god andrew
there was an there's new evidence out
there yeah
yeah you said if either one gets true
oh my god this is a bombshell so wait a
minute there was an
end earlier in the conference yes but
then you went further because
i of course being johnny cochran put you
on the spot
and i started to twist the screws a
little bit here
okay but judge ito we need a ruling here
because we have conflicting evidence
mclovin would you be the judge as a
former paralegal
do we i don't i think that's not a
partial deal
does andrew owe us a cheese shower of
shame yes
well i was gonna say isn't there some
kind of rule about um new evidence has
to be submitted to both sides before
entered into
uh some type of you've been watching too
many damn shows yeah
lauren order they're like it's depraved
indifference you can't just put this in
here
yes mclovin i mean if the and doesn't
fit you must have quit
there will be lawyers listen i think
next time then
we'll bring on an impartial third not
one of your not one of your guys
an impartial third uh legal
legal eagle to rule on my situation but
let's see what happens with watson too
um if watson's traded then we don't need
a legal expert to come on
correct yeah yeah
i'm a little bit stunned by the new
evidence i need time to consult with my
client
yeah you're like jack nicholson and uh
you know
you know tom cruise a code red did you
order the code red
yes macleod are you gonna offer him a
plea deal of something do you want a
plea deal
dan you can't handle the truth i can
handle the truth
do you want a plea deal
well we can negotiate something you know
i
we can figure something out if there's a
plea if we can double down on watson
you know and you give me a pass on this
deal
and then we double down if it happens
i'd have to see you in the judge's
chambers to talk about this okay i guess
why don't we just get judge judy
you imagine we we get judge judy on and
she hears that
you know what i'm going to see if judge
judy will join us one day how's that
that would be great would you trust
judge judy
yes i would trust her ruling i would
submit to her ruling
okay okay fritzi see if judge judy will
join us
on the case and if not we'll find
another judge but you know
somebody that andrew will approve of
okay uh andrew i hope i didn't ruin your
weekend
but um all good okay
uh great to talk to you again thank you
bud okay we'll check in soon thanks
all right that's andrew brandt the
monday morning quarterback columnist uh
businesses sports podcast former espn
legal and business animals